but I need the extra batteries to this
it's on the nightstand on the right I'm
trying to get you to work out I love you
I want you to live a long time you gonna
hit me I mean have you ever been into
like an actual fight like like a fist
fight with somebody because me and
bubbles oh I was on it right now it
looks like your boys already done rolled
out Flay oh that's funny Chris tell them
a god damn it what's the cutoff age for
that not like when you're like 1 or 2
years old I made an appointment
appointment I want to make an
appointment sweet over here after school
good for you SAT classes about 30
minutes but in between those 30 minutes
and a half an hour whoop yo ass
[__] you want me to google
calendar your ass it for an [__] but
ok this is what we gonna do you gonna
beat me up I'll stop my mom spot at 4:30
on the done you come 10 minute past I'm
already gone I got things to do I got
violin practice it's so is so easy to do
a drive-by on people not because they
[__] Instagram location they're asked
to fish so how'd you know where I was
you [__] have your location services
it's funny I had the worst temper to the
point where I could not do what you do
what a lot of people does he'll meet me
up after school yeah I was like I can't
do that I'm angry now because by the
time it's after school I'm hungry like
hunger would outweigh the answer so it's
like if you wanna fight now I'm not sure
to do man I got a delicious sandwich
waiting for me at home there's like
Kraft Mayo
it has a nice delicious light cured ham
what the delicious Kraft single by the
way and a nice crisp piece of lettuce
with some delicious Wonder Bread and you
want me to in on that in order to fight
you no no I never understood it's like
you'll meet me after school it's like
why we're here let's just do it now well
there's the witnesses I was in seventh
grade and in eighth grade there was a
bully
and I'm like a hillbilly type it's
redneck time looking back now I felt bad
for him he was quite just acting out
because you would have problems at home
but he once walked up to me it's like a
scarf or something in then he put it
around my neck and was kind of
instinctively turned around and then the
balls and then he just went down perfect
I was obviously I was very very nerdy
very skinny like that was the last thing
anyone ever expected me to do and so you
know my friends immediately just like
dispersed and told everyone who was
happening you know and I felt oddly like
maybe powered empowered yeah
and so a few weeks later there's another
bully and I was behind him in line I
accidentally kicked him to the foot
first stepped on his foot and he told me
he turned around and said something to
me and my instant reaction was just to
punch him in the face well he was just
basically turned out and say like can
you not kick me in the shoes did not
warrant a punch in the face and I
remember watching his face and him
starting to cry and I remember thinking
oh my god feels so bad like why did I do
that I'd let I let last week gets my
head why because you want to taste the
blood yeah you wanted it again and then
it was just like I was that was not
called for it because especially cuz I
started awful on the inside and I was
sitting at lunch with my friends and the
principal says it's
a good student good kid the principal
came out and he just like just stood in
front of me and he was just trying to
put it together and he was like what's
going on literally you just like I don't
why did you punch him in the face
I don't understand what you were
thinking I think I would've lied on the
spot he called my mother a [__] said
that he was going to stick his Peter
said my powers like excuse me if he was
a it was a penis reference a crazy-big
judgment you know better sex with a
llama and I was like don't do that -
Lamas what happened Chris he sniffed my
butthole
[Music]